Why Do We Call Crazy People a "Basket Cases"?
At first, “basket case” didn’t mean
someone who was crazy.
Instead, it referred to someone who had a
physical disability.
The phrase has its origins in World War I.
Funny enough, one of the earliest known documented
instances of the phrase was actually in denial
that “basket cases” actually existed,
as found in a bulletin issued in March of
1919 on behalf of the United States Surgeon
General:
The Surgeon General of the Army… denies…that
there is any foundation for the stories that
have been circulated…of the existence of
basket cases in our hospitals.
But just what was the Surgeon General referring
to when he said “basket case”?
When this bulletin came out, many newspapers
felt the need to define the phrase for their
audiences, so apparently the phrase wasn’t
widely used at this point.
They defined it as “a soldier who has lost
both arms and legs and therefore must be carried
in a basket.”
(The Syracuse Herald, March of 1919)
Whether they were literally carried around
in baskets as the newspapers stated or the
phrase originally was just referencing the
then common colloquial idea of associating
baskets with beggars or helplessness, given
the grisly nature of the First World War and
anecdotal reports, it seems plausible enough
that there probably were at least some “basket
cases,” despite the Surgeon General’s
denial.
As you can imagine, the original meaning of
“basket case” was never incredibly common.
It wasn’t until World War II that the phrase
prominently resurfaced.
Near the end of the war in May of 1944, once
again, the Surgeon General attempted to deny
that there were any basket cases:
…there is nothing to rumors of so-called
‘basket cases’—cases of men with both
arms and legs amputated.
After World War II, the original meaning fell
out of favor altogether, likely due to the
lack of literal basket cases.
However, for a while the phrase expanded to
mean someone with a physical disability who
was unable to get around by themselves easily.
Today, of course, it has further evolved to
mostly be a slang phrase for someone with
a mental disability, or someone who seems
to have been moved to act in a crazy fashion
for
whatever reason.